we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors steadymd lets you maintain a
meaningful long-lasting relationship
with a primary care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman ladies and gentlemen it is
uh an historic day
we now know that thanks to
democrats winning both senate runoffs
in georgia democrats will have
50 50 in the senate with joe biden
in the white house meaning that in any
cases of a 50-50
tie in the senate the vice president
kamala harris
will be allowed to cast the deciding
vote
in practical terms giving
democrats control of the senate
what they will be able to get done of
course will depend
on maintaining all 50 democratic
senators
united and uh it's almost cliche at this
point to say
but much of that will come down to does
joe manchin
the most conservative of the democrats
in the senate from west virginia
does joe manchin want to do many of the
things that joe biden
outlined uh in his presidential platform
or will joe manchin be the thorn in the
side of the democrats now of course
there are other democrats who in some
cases may not want to go with the biden
idea
there are at least theoretically some
republicans who might
you know the prototypical example is
that
the constituents for republican maine
senator susan collins
may be more to the left of the
constituents for democratic
senator in west virginia joe manchin and
these are more detail-level discussions
that we will have
in the future but what we do know uh
is that in terms of the kelly leffler
incumbent vs challenger rafael warnock
race
that one was called relatively early
last night
official calls starting around and after
midnight
david wasserman unofficially saying he
had seen enough of the data
to call it right around i believe it was
9 30 pm eastern maybe 10 p.m eastern
something like that
and indeed that race has been now called
officially with raphael warnock
ahead as of right now with 98 reporting
by 1.2 percentage points
the other race is incumbent senator
david perdue
a corrosive vile depraved
influence on the us senate who couldn't
even be
at the last rally that donald trump held
for the republicans because he was
in isolation due to covet exposure
that one has has been called by some
and not others but uh it is it is over
and officially as of right now john
ossoff with 98
reporting as of this moment um leading
by about half a point roughly 16
17 000 votes um and
that one is also one that some have
called and some have not and by the time
you listen to today's show
you may see that it has also been called
so consider
that under donald trump who won in 2016.
donald trump himself is ending up as a
one-term president and we are just
moments now and maybe by the time you
listen to this it will already be
underway
we are moments now from the official
counting of the electoral votes january
6 the absolute
i think last date that
trump cultists were saying this is the
date where mike pence can do something
for us
but trump becoming a one-term president
democrats taking the house of
representatives in 2018
and maintaining control in 2020 although
with a slightly smaller margin than they
than they achieved in 2018
and democrats also taking the senate
from republicans in 2020
back in 2017 the mathematical consensus
was pointing to
unlikely that democrats can take the
senate in 2020
but 2022 is certainly a possibility we
now have a situation where democrats
thanks of course to kamala harris in the
white house
democrats now will have control 50
plus that one tie-breaking vote in the
senate in 2020
and the possibility again depends on
what you get done but the possibility of
expanding
the senate majority in 2022
although we are very much getting ahead
of ourselves let's get this
new president sworn in first and
foremost
um i was thinking by the way back to
remember that uh
debate between kelly leffler and
challenger rafael warnock where she
endlessly repetitively
smeared or attempted to smear him as
radical liberal remember this radical
liberal raphael warnock radical liberal
raphael warnock radical liberal raphael
warnock
radical liberal rafael warnock radical
liberal rafael warnock
well as i tweeted last night that's
going to have to be modified
to be radical liberal senator
rafael warnock to you ms leffler and of
course
he's not really radical and that was
just part of the smear campaign
so in the end you know we'll look at
exit polls and we already know that
perspective on trump versus biden
heavily influenced people's votes in
georgia
we know that there was some antipathy
towards donald trump's attempts to steal
the election that joe biden legally won
and legally won
quite easily i i might add that did not
work in donald trump's favor
and we'll have time to slice and dice
the results but in the immediate
the question for me becomes listen
politics is not
sport for me politics is how does this
affect people's lives and unfortunately
there there are many for whom it is
merely sport and that's really a shame
but we have a global hundred year
pandemic we have an eviction crisis
we have high unemployment we've seen
dramatic gdp reductions
we have businesses that are closed for
good because of the virus
we've seen growing inequality and
there's this long and climate
is is an urgent crisis so there's this
long list here
of issues that joe biden is going to
have dropped on his desk
on day one what can he do via executive
order
uh what can he do legislatively in the
first hundred days
joe biden talking yesterday about if we
get these seats then we're looking at
two thousand
dollar checks well are you and how
quickly can you get that done
is that something we're going to do i uh
joined up
yesterday during our broadcast of the
georgia
results with uh sam cedar
over and and emma over at the majority
report and we talked about
um what is the uh
what is the trajectory here in terms of
what's prioritized
with regard to the virus sam's saying
well biden should immediately invoke the
defense production act
and get businesses making millions and
millions of doses of the
vaccine to accelerate that process
because the sooner we reach herd
immunity the sooner the economy is going
to recover
and the sooner we can get back to
dealing with a whole bunch of other
issues i think that that's something
that's going to have to be looked at but
uh for those who my last thought on this
i want to go to republican reaction to
this
but my last thought and you know part of
the conversation here we can't have
until we actually have that january 6
today
electoral vote count in the rear view
mirror i think a lot of us will just
feel more ready to talk about the first
hundred days of this administration and
new senate
but i i think the cautionary message is
all of these are moves in the right
direction but they're small moves we're
just sort of
we've gotten the ball back we're
starting to right the ship
as i've said before the
anti-intellectual
anti-science delusional extremist
authoritarian when we want to be but
otherwise we pretend to be
constitutional conservatives that this
entire paradigm on the right
was built up starting with ronald reagan
you could argue it goes back even
further to the civil rights movement and
and the sort of reaction to the civil
rights movement in the late 50s and 60s
but let's for our purposes today say
that the
disinformation right that tries to win
by lying to people and
disenfranchising people it sort of goes
back to the reagan era
with the imaginary welfare queen who was
uh sitting around popping out kids
and making money off welfare to get a
cadillac that that was like the idea she
never existed
okay this that trumpism today
and the trump cult really started with
that and it took decades to build
and so my only point here and then we'll
move on because there's so much to talk
about my only point here is
everything that's happened in the last
month two months helps us
to start riding the ship but it would be
unreasonable
to imagine that a problem that took 40
years to create is going to be solved in
two
or in four and as i've said before the
only times that you get radically fast
cultural change because a lot of this
comes down to culture
the anti-science culture the hypocrisy
culture of this stuff is all bad unless
we want to do it in which case it's good
that applies to debt authoritarianism
etc from the right
um the only times we see radical changes
to that type of culture
are when you have a dictatorship come in
okay so it's not
realistic to think that a democratic
senate and joe biden
is going to dramatically change that in
a two or four year period so the focus
has to be
we get things done that we can get done
and we
start to work on that culture it's a big
uphill battle but
could there were two races and democrats
won both of them you couldn't hope for a
better result
so donald trump has been freaking
out on twitter melting down since last
night
highly triggered by the senate results
and trump
again raising this idea of huge
dumps of votes the guy can't behave
normally for five minutes and donald
trump
even in advance of last night's results
which we actually knew relatively
quickly all things considered
tweeting around 10 pm last night looks
like they are setting up
a big voter dump against the republican
candidates
waiting to see how many votes they need
and of course this never happened donald
trump whatever massive dumps he was
involved in or believed were coming
it just never happened from the
standpoint of the race and in fact
democrats were winning early trump's
scenario is always
republicans are way ahead and then
massive dumps come in
and then democrats win democrats were
winning early and then the race is
tightened as more votes were counted
and then it was just slow slow slow
steady vote counts going one way and the
other and eventually it became clear
that democrats would win by a small
margin in both races because
outstanding votes were overwhelmingly
from very very blue areas areas areas
that went
um three to two for the democratic
challengers even even uh three to one in
some cases so
no massive dumps no small dumps just an
election that was counted
and and it was all pretty unremarkable
uh from the standpoint of
of election integrity and counting and
it really set trump off
and he spent most of the night tweeting
and retweeting stuff
uh tweeting at midnight eastern then at
1am calling on mike pence to steal him
the presidency saying quote
if vice president mike pence comes
through for us
we will win the presidency many states
want to decertify the mistake they made
in certifying incorrect and even
fraudulent numbers
in a process not approved by their state
legislatures which it must be
those are all lies by the way and trump
adds mike can send it back
that won't happen mike pence reportedly
explaining to trump yesterday i can't
overturn the results
and we'll talk a little bit about that
later based on a very good new york
times report but
finishing up with the trump meltdown
then this morning again
donald trump just out of control first
attacking reporter chuck todd
as sleepy eyes chuck todd
is so happy with the fake voter
tabulation process
that he can't even get the words out
straight sad to watch
and trump's anger knows no limits he
will attack
anybody for anything at any time when
he's melting down
again claiming quote states want to
correct their votes
which they now know were based on
irregular
irregularities and fraud plus corrupt
process never received legislative
approval
all mike pence has to do is send them
back to the states
and we win do it mike this is a time for
extreme courage and behind the scenes
there are reports
that trump is reportedly going to
absolutely turn on his own vice
president mike pence
if pence doesn't do something today when
the vote count starts
uh which we will be covering live and
then apparently realizing that the
senate is lost
donald trump sending out an all-caps
tweet this morning
saying the republican party and more
importantly
our country needs the presidency more
than ever before the power of the veto
suggesting democrats will have the house
democrats will have the senate
you need me there to veto the things
that they will do
truly crumbling before our very eyes
the republican party collapsing around
donald trump
and uh we we essentially have to see
what else he breaks on the way out whoa
my microphone they're
flipping out there we have to see what
else he breaks on the way out as i've
said before there's a reason that many
companies will
escort folks out when their position has
been terminated
right away and it's to prevent them from
doing damage on the way out and of
course donald trump having months
during which he can do that damage so
later today we will talk about the
conversation where mike pence had to
explain to trump i i can't just overturn
the results
we will talk about what to expect over
the next few days
let me know your reaction to the
democratic winds in georgia
i'm on twitter deepakman the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call
with your new doctor you establish a
meaningful relationship with them and
after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays i took their
quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs they have a special offer
only for my audience you'll get 50 off
your first month but only until january
31st so make sure to sign up soon
click the link right underneath this
video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that the david pakman show is
mostly
funded by memberships which you can grab
at joinpackman.com and use the coupon
code if you want
better21 all one word all lowercase
better21 to
save massively off of a membership
at joinpakman.com so yesterday
a day before presiding over a joint
session of congress to
confirm the victory of joe biden as the
next president of the united
states uh joe by uh mike pence rather
vice president mike pence met with
donald trump and reportedly
told him i can't overturn
the election results donald trump has
been increasingly pointing to mike pence
saying we've got to count on mike pence
mike pence has to come through
for us and that's code 4 figure out a
way to steal an election that we
actually didn't win
and the new york times is now reporting
that mike pence quote
tried to lower the president's
expectations while
seeking ways to mollify him this is an
article
by annie carney and maggie haberman
where they say vice president mike pence
told trump on tuesday that he didn't
believe he had the power to block
congressional certification of joe
biden's win in the presidential election
which is true he doesn't
despite trump's baseless insistence that
he did
and this is according to multiple people
a briefed on the content of the
conversation this took place during the
weekly lunch
that mike pence has with donald trump
and
this was just hours after trump started
publicly pressuring
mike pence to essentially
steal the election for him i mean we we
have to call things what they are and
these euphemisms about
making sure all legal votes are counted
we have the election results in every
state
those results have been certified the
electors have then certified their votes
and today and it may be happening as we
speak
it may be done by the time you listen to
today's show or watch this clip
the uh joint session of the house and
senate is counting
those votes um trump tweeted
the president has the power to reject
fraudulently chosen electors
and uh of course it is not true that
there were fraudulently chosen electors
none of this is true
and most importantly uh mike pence
cannot
alter the results mike pence can hear
objections from senators
and members of the house which we expect
to hear
there can be debate about that we heard
that
tim scott and james inhofe two
radical right senators are uh
saying that they will not be
participating in these attempts to
undermine the results but reportedly 11
or 12 republican senators
are going to so there's a few different
aspects to this number one
january 20th really couldn't get here
any faster we're down to exactly two
weeks
um two weeks to the day joe biden will
be getting sworn in
and trump will be we don't know where
and i'll talk actually about that a
little bit later
i would love to have been a fly on the
wall during the conversation
where pence is explaining to trump i
can't just
alter the results i can't just declare
ourselves i can't declare you and i the
winners i
i just can't do it how is trump reacting
during that conversation
was he furious was he resigned was he
sad was he mopey trump
and then even after this conversation
took place where mike pence told trump i
can't do the thing you want me to do
trump insisted on twitter that he can
again trump tweeting we looked at this
tweet earlier
if vice president mike pence comes
through
for us we will win the presidency
many states want to decertify the
mistake they made
in certifying incorrect and even
fraudulent numbers in a process
not approved by their state legislatures
which it must be
mike can send it back and he can't
so let's do kind of a gut check
consider how insane it is that this is
something that happened
the president is told by the vice
president i can't steal the election
and it's newsworthy it is newsworthy
because that is exactly what the
president wants the vice president to do
things are so nutty that it is actually
noteworthy that a vice president had to
sit the president down and talk to him
like a big boy and say i can't steal the
election
for you now as a reminder the line of
reasoning
that it takes to assume mike pence can
do this is that mike pence
as the presiding officer of this joint
session to count
electoral votes can say i am going to
ignore
certain electoral votes as decided by
the states oh
the pennsylvania electoral votes i'm
going to ignore them we're not going to
count those
and there's this alternate slate of
electors which is just random people
it's not there's nothing legally binding
i'm going to accept
as an alternate slate of electors these
20 republicans who showed up and did
something of no legally binding uh
importance and said we vote for trump
pence doesn't have the power to do that
and
a number of interesting procedural and
congressional law experts over the last
few days have given
interviews to that effect i'm not
bothering to play them because i think
most of my audience understands that
trump's dying words really may be
we totally won georgia we totally won
pennsylvania in 2020.
he may repeat that to his dying day but
trump's leaving in two weeks
and the concern of course is how are the
trump cultists going to react
as a sort of preview for how trump
cultists may react in two weeks when
trump is finally gone
yesterday there was a pro-trump rally in
advance
of today's counting of the electoral
votes in washington dc
and it is really something to behold
this is compelling culturally
psychologically politically
scientifically
it's really important for us to
understand that
this contingent these factions exist
and they are very radical to pretend
that they don't exist doesn't do us
any good it achieves nothing to pretend
they don't exist
so let's look at some clips and remember
that the real point here is that it's a
pro-trump rally
to support donald trump stealing the
election from joe biden
now ostensibly this is a political
rally saying trump actually won let's
figure out how to take it
okay that's crazy but that's ostensibly
what this is
but the way in which the trump was
rigged stuff
overlaps with anti-vaccine nonsense
it overlaps with anti-semitism of course
it overlaps with anti-science ideology
it's important to understand the sort of
venn diagram
because it confirms much of what
conspiracy experts have told us i've
interviewed many conspiracy experts on
the show
and they almost uh unanimously say
some conspiracy theories seem benign
flat earth for example you believe the
earth is flat you can't really do
anything with that
you're not going to be able to push
people off the edge because there is no
edge etc
but the point is that certain people are
just more prone to believe conspiracies
and so when we say flat earth is benign
okay but those same people are
predisposed to believe
other stuff that is more dangerous and
has more real world
implications so let's get right into it
here is one speaker
referring to the deceptively named
biological agent known as a vaccine
that's a quote take a listen
must not comply if you don't want to
take an experimental biological agent
deceptively named a vaccine
you must not allow yourself to be
coerced
if you are living in fear of a
non-lethal virus
simply buy the same cheap ordinary
medicines used across the world
when you know something to be false you
must reject it
period when you know something to be
true you must stand up for it
and you must be willing to fight for it
i urge you to mark this day this moment
as a united return of our nation to the
eternal fight for freedom
a commitment to integrity a resolve to
seek the truth in all arenas
and to always act upon it americans
god bless america okay so that's
pro-trump steal the election insanity
merged with anti-vaxx conspiracies
that's one example as to how these
groups
interact all right here is pro-trump
steal the election
stuff merging with more general
anti-communist hugo chavez conspiracy
theories
which we've heard before who knows that
sequoia smartmatic
and that company was founded by hugo
chavez in communist venezuela
step three your vote your votes were
exported
and then of course much of this also
combining
with the anti-science stuff that
directly leads to coveted deaths
and and it's all kind of wrapped up in
this clip with religiosity because i
guess
jesus would say don't wear a mask you
tell me so what i'm asking you to do
right now
is to do the great reset in a good way
okay we're going to reframe it last
night about 150 of us went into whole
foods
and we dressed up like people that
aren't idiots hiding from a virus that's
not
deadly we did not wear a mask
who here is up to the task of not
wearing a mask
[Applause]
i ask you again who here is up to the
task of not wearing a mask
jesus is king and it's time to let
freedom ring ladies and gentlemen
so that's i guess claiming that the word
of
god is not to wear
masks during a pandemic and that same
guy
also claimed that covid tests are fake
what that even means i don't know but
let's take a listen the pcr
tests are fake the covet 19
pcr tests are fake and if you go to my
podcast
you can hear interviews you can hear the
founder of the pcr test kerry mullins
explaining to you
the pcr tests are supposed to be
calibrated at
17 someone should write this down 17 to
20 cycles
those are calibrated at 40 cycles what
does that mean
it means that it's like your speedometer
is telling you you're driving
400 miles an hour when you're driving
seven miles an hour
so the covet tests are fake that's
that's actually a new one
and then we get into the anti-semitism
now it's about george soros
a jewish man secretly controlling
supreme court justices just a typical
anti-semitic dog whistle now our next
speaker
is one of the most fiery
activists i've ever known
she's tireless she's relentless
she will do research she's the only
person i know who does
she watches george soros speeches for
fun
but you know what happened when she
looked one of those up
she found that he was talking about
chief justice john
roberts like george soros owned him
lynn wood retweeted it for she gets this
information because she never stops
fighting george soros is controlling
john roberts george soros is the real
puppet master
of the chief justice of the supreme
court that's the idea and
as i've said before you have to know
what you're listening for that's the
thing about dog whistles it's much like
when you blow a dog whistle
the dog has ears tuned to hear it so
they hear the whistle
it's the same thing with these
anti-semitic tropes and dog whistles you
have to understand
the context and what what they're
referring to and then lastly
alex jones doesn't need much of an
introduction
not looking good not sounding good but
saying very very wild things
we don't quietly take the election fraud
we don't quietly take the scam
and believe their bs we've seen the
evidence
the system has had to desperately
engage in this gambit to maintain
control but this will be
their waterloo this will be
their destruction
whatever happens to president trump in
15 days
he is still the elected president
of this republic and we do not recognize
the communist chinese agent joe
biden or his controllers
yeah so that's uh again it's either a
character that he's playing
or a very very sick guy so my
question i sort of have a short term and
a medium term question on these folks
short term is what do they do tomorrow
when the vote will have been certified
uh the electoral vote will have been
counted in the house and senate for joe
biden
what do they do on january 20th when
trump leaves
do they get violent what happens that's
the short-term question
the more medium-term question is do
these people even stay engaged with the
political world
many of them were never engaged before
trump they were sort of they sort of
joined politics
um directly into the trump cult and
i don't know the answer as to whether
they just get out of politics or they
stay
and much of it might depend on what
trump does for the next two or four
years does trump remain engaged in
politics
or does he disappear to wherever will
allow him and just kind of play golf and
sit around
questions we don't yet have answers to
and we'll continue covering this
uh and these events on our instagram
where you can find us
at david pakmansha the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one
sitting that's exactly what one of my
favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to dot
com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
this is funny to see um
one of trump's kids eric trump went on
the fox news program hosted by sean
hannity last night
and i have clips of both eric trump and
his wife
uh lara trump actually the the power
couple of sorts
just really struggling to cope with the
defeat uh
really defeat after defeat that the
republican party is suffering trump
losing
these interviews happening as republican
incumbents in georgia
in the senate were also losing and um
as the interview went on you see
that they are now starting to become
vindictive in a sense and in this first
clip eric trump says
seemingly acknowledging that they've
lost everything
that the maga movement is going nowhere
but more importantly eric trump
threatens
any republican who today january 6 when
the house and senate
convened to count the electoral votes
that may already be happening by the
time you listen today
eric trump trump warns we are going to
have a list
any republican that doesn't help today
to steal the election
you were getting primaried of course
this assumes that
trump will have any kind of power after
he leaves office we still don't know
that
uh but here is eric trump tomorrow's
gonna tell you a lot about the country
because i i can tell you sean any
senator or any congressman that does not
meaning on this side that does not fight
tomorrow i'm telling you will not
their political career is is is over
because um the maga movement is going
it's going nowhere my father's created
the greatest political movement in
american history and
i'm telling you they will get primary
the next time around and they will lose
if they don't stand up and show some
backbone and show some conviction
so there it is eric trump threatening
the political careers
of any republican who doesn't get in
line
shut their mouth or i guess open their
mouth to support
the trump coup that is destined to fail
imagine saying by the way
this is really delusional after losing
the house in 2018 so trump gets elected
in 2016.
republicans lose the house in 2018 don't
get it back in 2020.
they lose the senate in 2020 and trump
becomes a one-term president which is of
course not unheard of but it's
relatively rare i mean it's tough to
remove an incumbent president
and eric trump has the audacity to say
trumpism is the greatest political
movement in history
this is the type of delusion where we
narcissists don't realize when they have
no leverage
that's a really important characteristic
of very serious narcissism and of course
eric trump was i mean i guess raised by
it's not really clear who raised these
trump kids trump it's not clear trump
likes his kids that much
but at least in some vague sense they
were raised by donald trump at least the
idea of donald trump as their father
and trump much like his kids they don't
know when they don't have leverage
very often they do have leverage they
are powerful people and they've been
powerful
really most of their lives um and and
there's no denying that but even when
they no longer
have the leverage they still think they
do and eric trump
saying this is the greatest political
movement you've lost everything why are
you assuming
that you're going to continue having
leverage or influence over the party
they might but they might not and then
eric trump
still claiming that there's just no way
joe biden got all those votes
no one believes that this guy got 80
million votes it doesn't feel right it
doesn't look right
again with the feelings i thought facts
didn't care about
your feelings i've heard that from the
right for a decade at this point
but he just doesn't feel like donald
trump really lost
so what do we do with that i guess as
far as they're concerned
you steal the election and then the
softball interviews with trump family
members continued last night on fox eric
trump's wife
lara trump also appearing
and hilariously she is still being
identified as trump campaign senior
advisor
which of course should make us ask what
campaign are you talking about that
campaign ended
two months ago senior adviser to the
campaign
and she says i truly believe
trump will probably consider
running in 2024 what a strong statement
right but
talking about 2024 does implicitly
concede that donald trump lost this time
so that's something but
she's still kind of careful not to say
it take a listen look if he does not
remain president for the next four years
i truly believe that he will probably
consider running again in 2024 i believe
he would win in 2024
by a larger margin of victory than he
even did uh then
i guess the more votes than he had in
this election but
so that that's just really amazing i
mean first of all what conviction right
lara
i really do believe that
if he doesn't get another four years now
he will
probably consider running
in 2024. to me that means he's not
running running in 2024.
uh that that that's what i'm hearing
from the language that lara trump is
using but
the uh uh coping uh mechanisms
are very different for different folks
in the republican party there are those
who are just abandoning all together and
pretending none of this horrible thing
ever happened
there are those who are still insisting
any second now trump's going to be sworn
in in fact i posted to my twitter you
can see it
this morning i posted a message i got
today there i posted this message i got
today
and people thought it was months old
today someone said to me david don't you
realize
trump's getting a second term right now
biden's not
um so some people continuing to be in
denial and
i know that there's just one cautionary
uh
mention here i know there are people in
my audience waiting for the big payoff
where on january 22nd all of these
people admit they were wrong
you're not going to get that you're not
going to get that satisfaction because
on january 20th 21st 22nd
they will come up with some new thing
and say
it was stolen in this way and that way
and none of it is legitimate so if
you're waiting for that satisfaction
you're going to be waiting a very long
time this is absolutely fascinating in
the last 24 hours we learned
about a possible plan for donald trump
to flee the country
to scotland either on the day of or the
day before joe biden's inauguration and
just as quickly we learned
that donald trump isn't going to be
allowed to do that by scottish
authorities
now some of you may know that donald
trump has a much beleaguered golf club
in
scotland called turnberry and
speculation has been growing over the
last day day and a half
that donald trump was planning to leave
the united states and head there after
joe biden's inauguration
because of a high amount of surveillance
planes in the area believed to be sort
of laying the groundwork for trump to be
there for some period of time
we also are aware of the scheduling of a
flight arrival there on january 19th of
a u.s military
boeing 757 a truck a plane that donald
trump sometimes
flies on and as quickly as that plan
came together
the scottish first minister nicola
sturgeon has blocked the plan
making it clear that trump coming here
to play golf during a pandemic
that's not essential travel and it's not
going to be allowed
here she is saying it's a no-go i have
no idea what donald trump's travel plans
are
um you'll be glad to know
um i hope and expect
that as everybody hopes and it's what as
everybody expects
not everybody necessarily will hope that
the travel plan
immediately that he has is to exit the
white house
um but beyond that i don't i don't know
but it's
not uh you know we are not uh allowing
people to come into scotland for
uh without an essential purpose right
now and that would apply
to him just as it applies to anybody
else and
coming to play golf is not what i would
consider to be an essential purpose
isn't that just amazing and as usual the
white house
initially put out a non-denial you
you have to read between the lines with
all of this stuff the white house was
initially asked
is trump planning to leave the country
to go to scotland on the 19th or 20th
and uh jude dear the deputy white house
press secretary
said anonymous sources who claim to know
what the president is considering have
no idea
when we have an announcement about
january 20th we will let you know
so as you can see nothing in there
that's a denial
and once it became clear that trump
wouldn't even be allowed in scotland the
white house put out another carefully
worded statement saying
the president has no plans to travel to
scotland
on that date and again that may
technically be true
the plan that may have existed would
likely now no longer exist
because trump's been told you can't come
in uh but in all seriousness
can you imagine a funnier headline than
former president trump denied entry to
scotland and hilariously
if the plan was to go there on january
19th
he'd still be the president president
trump denied entry to scotland
is even funnier and the truth is when
the u.s
sends former presidents to scotland
they're not sending their best
they're sending a grifter con man and
scotland
seems to think they need to shut it down
until they can figure out what the hell
is going on
trump actually might have to be in the
united states during joe biden's
inauguration despite his best efforts
and we know that would be really
triggering to donald trump
someone wrote to me saying david he's
not really planning to go to scotland
trump is pretending to be planning to go
to scotland
but he's really going to go to a country
without an extradition treaty to the
united states the u.s and scotland
do have an extradition treaty for
example russia and the u.s do not
china and the u.s do not but i think the
idea falls short because trump wouldn't
be using a military plane
to go somewhere to avoid extradition to
the united states i know people
love talking about trump fleeing to
russia
or wherever wherever else i don't
actually think trump's going to do that
i
i also believe that putin is enough of a
troll
that he probably would also say no to
trump i don't know
uh i know that the the optics of a
former u.s president fleeing to russia
would be really good propagandistically
for russia
but i also know that putin is a pretty
clever guy
and he may even find it funnier to say
no to donald trump but
at the bottom line this is all mere
speculation it's really a story
about once again donald trump's
narcissism
scotland is closed to travel due to the
pandemic
and trump may well have the idea that he
can just fly in and play golf
two more weeks my friends we are almost
there what will trump do
i don't know we will know in the next
two weeks much will be revealed very
very soon
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world-famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as
commercial-free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpackman.com that's join
pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
vote soon 18 all one word all lower case
become a member today
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
this is a beautiful clip i think you're
going to like this one and this is
really informative this will open up a
conversation that i think is a really
um important one to be having fox news
host lou dobbs fox business okay fox
news we can still say
fox business host lou dobbs was visibly
confused
about why they just can't seem to find
any evidence of all the voter fraud that
he is damn sure took place
so let's look at the clip first and then
we'll discuss and we still don't have
verifiable tangible support
for uh the uh for the
the crimes that everyone knows we're
committed
that is defrauding other
citizens who voted with fraudulent votes
we know that's the case in nevada we
know it's the case in pennsylvania
and a number of other states but we have
had a
double of a time uh finding actual
proof uh why this this is just perfect
so
lou dobbs has been one of the biggest
promulgators and platformers of
completely deranged
harebrained fraud conspiracy theories on
fox news and fox business
he's platformed that wacky lawyer sydney
powell
he's platformed um so-called witnesses
to voter fraud who couldn't actually
come up with any real claims of anybody
doing anything wrong
and now after all of that lou just isn't
sure
why they can't find any actual proof
of it it's always just out of reach the
proof that they need
now a more sensible approach would be
well damn if there are a hundred
different claims
about a hundred different types of fraud
and i can find no evidence for any of
them
maybe the fraud doesn't exist but the
absence of evidence
becomes part of the conspiracy theory
and we've talked about that before
more generally and this is actually one
of the important signals
that you're dealing with conspiracy
theorists for whom facts and evidence
don't actually matter
healthy skepticism about the world is
good
bottomless skepticism is not so good and
with conspiracy theorists once they've
decided
what went down if they can't find
evidence
the fact that they can't find evidence
becomes part of the reason they are
skeptical
it cannot be proven wrong it is
indefeasible if evidence
and lack of evidence prove the
conspiracy you're not talking to someone
who reasoned their way into their belief
and you're not going to be able to
reason them out of it
conspiratorial thinking as opposed to
healthy skepticism conspiratorial
thinking is immune to contradictory
evidence
or lack of evidence altogether the
cover-up is so perfect
they covered up all the evidence and we
can't find it that's part of the
conspiracy
uh peter bogosian refers to this in his
book as
dog doxastic closure it's a belief or
system
of beliefs that resists revision at a
systemic structural level
this is often the problem with religious
beliefs based on so-called
sacred texts hey this is true because
the sacred text
says so and the sacred text is sacred
well what proof do you have that the
sacred text is really the word of god
well you read the sacred text and it
says this is a sacred text and it's the
word of god okay well right but
is there something from outside the
sacred text
that tells us this really is a sacred
text
uh well no i mean that but that's part
of the problem of course not
of course of course we have to go to the
sacred text
to see if it tells us that it is a
sacred text that is a that's a
closed circle you can never pierce that
and
it's a very important lesson for
something to be on the lookout for
and it's also funny because lou dobbs is
so close
he's so close you know i've been
repeating this stuff for months
and we just can't find any actual
evidence why not
maybe i'm wrong but he doesn't get there
instead it's explain to me how they've
kept the evidence hidden from us
for so long and i don't know maybe
someone in
uh maybe someone in his audience heard
that and said oh maybe there's no
evidence because
there's really no evidence because it's
not true i don't know
but it's funny to see the gears sort of
the gears start grinding but they got
jammed up as lou dobbs was thinking it
through
republican senator mitt romney was
confronted yesterday in an airport it
looks like uh
dca in washington dc from the video that
we are going to play
you all know i didn't vote for mitt
romney in 2012 i voted for barack obama
you all know mitt romney is a
conservative
republican completely not in line with
my politics but mitt romney in this
particular confrontation
with the complete and utter loon sounds
eminently reasonable and completely
respectful and polite
even when he really has no reason to be
given how he's being treated
in this video you are going to see the
end result
of the heat romney has been taking from
the right from the pro-trump right
because while mitt romney is a
right-wing religious republican
he has refused to indulge donald trump
in some of his authoritarian insanity
mitt romney
didn't vote for trump in the
presidential election mitt romney on one
of two impeachment counts actually did
vote to convict mitt romney in the
senate
and in this video mitt romney is
accosted in the airport and he's way
more polite than many people would have
been to this woman when mitt romney
is the calming voice of reason in a
conversation
you know things are crazy and that they
are with this
maga cult that is here and is likely
going to be with us for some period of
time so let's look at the video
we joined the video with mitt romney
sitting by himself at the airport
with his mask on as required approached
by a maskless person we might call her a
maskless holy karen
if we wanted some kind of name let's
join the video
how you doing
don't tell me what to do please put your
mask on it's it's required by law in the
circle
i'm standing six feet away i'm sorry
okay i'll tell you what because you know
what i'm gonna go ahead and do it
because i wanna have a chat with you
so first of all i don't need a mask
because i'm six feet away
you're in the airport the air airports
require masks
lady uh and that's just a microcosm of
how they make up the rules as they as
they go along
as they want them to be let's continue
why aren't you supporting president
trump
i do support the things president trump
does that i think i agree with
you're not supporting him i'm sorry i do
agree with many of the things he
is for and i support those things are
you going to support him in the uh
the fraudulent votes the election no i'm
not why not
because i got a chance to hear my
remarks
it's gonna be a real one i'm sorry can
you say that again uh it's a long
uh story but the we have a constitution
the constitutional process is clear
i'll follow the constitution and i'll
explain all that we meet in congress
so mitt romney has asked why won't he
support
trump trying to steal the election
and romney says because we have a
constitution
and you would think that these
constitutional fetishists if they were
actually committed to constitutionality
would respect that in mitt romney but no
it actually makes her more angry and
this is one of my favorite moments
well you haven't supported him and you
didn't even support him in the election
no i did not why for reasons i explained
at the time
you were voted in as a conservative to
represent the conservative
constituents period actually that's not
how the constitution works
now that's fascinating for a few reasons
she says
you were voted in as a conservative
republican to represent conservatives
and there there's two things there first
as mitt
points out he's elected to represent his
entire constituency
and to defend the constitution stealing
an election that trump lost is not
constitutional but there's also this
idea
that even a conservative republican like
mitt romney
isn't really conservative unless he's
trying to steal the election for trump
when in reality there's nothing
conservative about trying to execute an
unconstitutional coup
when trump lost the election let's watch
more
it is you're voted in to represent us
you work for us
am i wrong i work for the people of utah
exactly and i am from utah but you're
not the only one
i voted i know there's a lot of people
that didn't vote for you
we'll make sure that one of course will
be private
that's totally perfect you admit it you
know it you know it's coming
they didn't want you in there anyway so
to be honest with you i wouldn't be
surprised if if you weren't even
if you weren't even voted in legally so
there mitt romney
starts walking uh but again two more
things to note
first the woman and a guy also there
say you're gonna get primary like a
threat and mitt romney says
of course that's fine that's that's the
process they're threatening him
with something that he supports being
part of the system and
and it's not praise of mitt romney's
political views but
he at least has not become so divorced
from just the the fundamentals of how
politics works
he's a that's not really i deserve to be
primary that that's the system
being primary that's what we do and then
the woman throws in you weren't even
voted in legally
and that's really scary that's scary
because
it's now completely acceptable in the
maga cult
to off-handedly say about any elected
official that you don't like
or who doesn't support what you want to
do in this case try to steal the
election
it's now acceptable to say you weren't
even voted in legally
i've never heard any question about the
legality
uh or or um integrity
of the election in which mitt romney won
and that's the long-term danger that i
spoke about with sam cedar last night as
we were watching the georgia
senate results come in the normalization
and the degradation of our politics
where with trump saying it was rigged
and i won
many of his followers fell for it and
then now they apply it to any election
of any politician that they don't like
you weren't even elected legally
and then lastly once he got on the plane
things weren't much better
for mitt romney trump people starting to
chant traders
drainer
[Applause]
so anyway it must have been a beautiful
fight for a flight there for uh for for
mitt romney so
democrats held the house in 2020 they
won the senate and won the white house
but this is going to be a very very long
two years the cultists are going to be
with us the question is how engaged will
they be as i mentioned earlier
and we will be with you in following it
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a little something for you just
about delusion uh we have this regular
right-wing caller troy york he always
calls in under fake names and i think he
gives one in this voicemail this is a
voicemail from this morning
we know that democrats have taken the
senate democrats won
in georgia and troy still
says that republicans are going to sweep
georgia i don't even know what he's
it's over the the races are over yes
david david packman um this is woody
underwood again
um calling back and i just want to say
before i was come up i think georgia
the republicans are going to sweep
georgia it's over
uh i think it's going to be a close
election because if they have not been
raped
as of yet and um
pretty much uh that's it i think you
have to be more effectual
with your reporting on the georgia
candidates
it it's over and this is so weird
because that
you might think oh that he left that
voicemail the day before the election no
it's been called the the races have been
called and
he left that voicemail around uh
9 30 in the morning on uh today
wednesday
after the election after the races have
been called so i don't know maybe it's
someone who's not really paying
attention or who thinks the elections
tonight or
i'm not really sure but um these are
these are folks who are going to
continue being around so that's a real
challenge
on the bonus show today no charges
will be filed against the officer who
shot jacob blake
uh we will be discussing that evictions
as per a new study evictions in the era
of coronavirus in the u.s
have led to more than ten thousand
additional cova deaths
and 430 000 additional coveted cases
incredible and then lastly on the bonus
show
the pennsylvania republican party
refused to swear in a re-elected
democratic senator
they have been emboldened in their
authoritarian anti-democratic
instincts by what we have seen donald
trump do since november 4th
uh was it now i don't even remember was
the election on the third or fourth i
think it was the fourth
um in claiming victory where there is no
victory
in claiming that he could just take the
election if he wants of course he can't
and didn't
but that has become a mind virus
that has spread dangerously through much
of the republican party so we will talk
about that on today's bonus show how do
you get the bonus show it's so easy
you go to joinpakman.com and you sign up
it takes under a minute
if you want a discount off of a
membership
i believe the regular prices are very
reasonable
but if you want a discount i'm glad to
offer it you can use the coupon code
better21 all one word no space better 21
because we're hoping for a better 2021
than was
2020 globally sign up get the bonus show
i'll speak to you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
steadymd lets you maintain a meaningful
long-lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with any anytime over
phone or video chat you don't need
insurance it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman